hi I'm Greg and I'm John welcome patron
chicks that's what I'm calling the
reaction surreal patrons and Friends
brakes met chicks so on our YouTube
channel the real rejects you know we
have the only thing that people really
watch are the reactions the reviews and
the sketches whenever we get around to
doing one of those and it's like the
main yeah is stuff that seems to drive
everything and stuff like the movie news
yeah no uh gut monitor we do we've
experimented with different ways because
we feel we can cover movie news pretty
well actually yeah so we tried movie
news of the week segment where we just
cram all the movie news of the week into
one you know like five minute video and
then and then we also tried doing like
okay it spread out the movie news
segments and then just do like one story
at a time and we can go into depth on
them so we're taking both of those ideas
and jamming them into just one long
uncut movie news segment not multiple
cameras because we're better than
Collider movie ha you guys get access to
this special video segment actually
because how many people put segments on
patreon yeah
well we're doing it we're going to do it
we're doing it we're going to clear
right there so welcome to our new
segment
m83 dream junkies news we're thinking of
doing a green screen thing for our set
to give it a little different background
but today we're just like Jeremy jumps
to make it stand out for you guys this
is a this is going to grow over time I
know Matt we're gonna together we're
going to shape what this show should be
I don't know if you heard the news
David Fincher nadir oh boy the finchy
the Finchel in [ __ ] wanna mild is it
Mike direct World War Z - really pretty
much set that he's going to do it but
there hasn't been a like 100%
confirmation just yet or official
greenlight there's a good amount of
assumes that certainly have elements of
horde panic row 7 that those zodiac even
alien 3 it bodes well in the terms of
he's worked with Brad Pitt before
so they have a rapport so easy yeah it
is kind of Brad Pitt's baby - cos damn
it was a Mark Zuckerberg and yeah yeah
and even also that is a guy in a girl
drink yeah yeah hang on sorry yeah yeah
yeah cuz in the social network they idh
didn't just and that was the one they
did it on right yes the one remark over
is aging younger you could tone it down
now and do a little bit more exploration
okay and give and make it an r-rated
flick this time Blade Runner 2049
trailer premiering before alien covenant
guys those faces this trailer will most
likely drop on the Internet
but for any of you see it before it is
alien covenant actually play don't they
know there's a handful of people that do
reactions we need to get this trailer up
they can't watch it before the movie
come on
these handful of people man version to
go with a GoPro night vision then
Harrison Ford's a very important
character in it he's not in it
throughout it's mainly about Ryan
Gosling trying to find him for something
there's like some type of mission where
Ryan Gosling has to find Harrison Ford's
character I really hope that this
trailer gets us a good look at who Ryan
Gosling character is because I think
they'll be especially I think they might
be a little letdown how do I can you
play Metal Gear Solid 2 and you know
snakes in it but you don't realize oh
you don't really get to spend that much
time with snake it's mainly with this
really good-looking young guy I did it
right around the Brian Gosling could be
divided into Blade Runner 2040 because
the theory we're going to be going it
hoping to see like Harrison Ford
throughout this film hey The Chronicles
of Narnia this is based on the fourth
book and it's applied this was the
kickstart and all new franchise and it's
being directed by Joe Johnston titles
include a wide variety of rate - ok
that's pretty bad yeah just been hopping
around with these damn books I feel like
when they do their movie
like why didn't you guys just start from
one and continue from there my guess is
they're all unrelated stories never
let's skip right to the lines over there
I would just start back in the beginning
now yeah mine is wet right yeah just
like and this is like this again this
could be a cool opportunity to make a
sort of anthology like series where you
get even different filmmakers to tell
the different stories and then if you
have to once you've done all seven eight
books nine books then you can launch off
and do your own inspired by the series
oh [ __ ] I feel like Chronicles narnia it
would be a great Netflix show it might
be hard to do a lot of the budget stuff
and make it look great I think Netflix
will have the money one day do something
like awesome well that John yeah
language to talk about the thing that we
and everyone's freaking out about yeah
and we've talked about this we have for
many times before even mentioning before
was even official confirmation from M
night Shyamalan the split unbreakable
sequel what's happening yep the
crossover hit of the summer called the
Corning Glass laughs you know he did
unbreakable years ago and the original
this was like over a decade ago and the
original idea you wanted Kevin's
character to be in there so this has
been a passion project for him yeah so I
can see why now that he has the
opportunity to do that film keeps so
vocal about it and passionate and and
it's like no I'm not gonna do it I feel
like I finally have the opportunity to
do the full of water difficulty gages
call this his MCU midnight they did it a
but night and it was with the M stance
or does never marble since wherever ends
dance over identified Schemmel Hong's
name the Emma period exactly dr. Malcolm
Malcolm X's return for Jurassic world do
what I says what I said to John was I
think they should get the whole original
cast from Jurassic Park once and Jeff
Goldblum's grown-up black daughter from
from Dredd galosh were all deferred yeah
she's all grown up
she's played by so I fell down
rosario dawson get it on back to get
ahead and get a oh [ __ ] who hurt
Julianne Moore and Moore back yeah I
think you should get just from the
people from the first to the [ __ ] is
Jurassic world to going to be about it
should be the indominus rex is child
dinosaur yeah who wants revenge he has a
first naturally born one but it wasn't
in writing right so they call in dr.
malcolm because they're gonna need some
help from someone who has experience but
i don't i don't know what the hell we
need a k audition to tell us that this
ideas it's never once worth it really
could maybe work from it in and future
look like that they give it a Jurassic
world to in a different direction where
they get him involved to help open up
the park again to so that way they have
you know dr. Malcolm like being able to
here's how you can keep these dinosaurs
under control I just I don't know see
how it could be we're gonna part it is
you're absolutely throughout the world
would be cool if it became if the world
of Jurassic world became Jurassic world
it's a-workin time so they get Planet of
the Apes again okay you can't open up a
park again in Jurassic world to know and
you can't just do like we got to go to
an island where we have other dinosaurs
there or something if it picks up right
after Jurassic world one yes sure yeah
was like everything just been destroyed
you're picking up on like the next day
yeah I might work that might be kind of
cool actually yeah it would make sense
weather still on this what can I going
to do now well I we got here Malcolm you
pick yeah maybe he'll come in halfway
through and be like the he'll be
laurence fishburne it turns out that he
gave up on living him running the
operation the entire telling this whole
yeah from a special compound
like in Chains but just James Bond I
suppose that that's going to be more of
a mystery thriller about the humans and
will fit my star in angley's clone
assassin movie Gemini man here's the
plot an aging assassin presumably that
would be plain looking to retire when he
comes up against the ultimate opponent a
younger clone of himself here's why I'm
intrigued Ainley is a damn good director
and lately he hasn't done like eglee
action films like my first angley movie
was crashing Tiger Hidden Dragon
yes I believe five as well wonderfully
by the Hulk hell yeah it seems like a
night you think consumed 9 either early
few thousand twins fighting each other
and after some reason I was thinking
about iRobot right now I'm thinking
about every John Claude Van Damme
there's one movie that thought did it
pretty well the one would gently I
thought they'd captured it pretty well
and they managed to still make it look
pretty cool cuz if they were doing two
different fighting styles fighting each
other so they had good choreography and
the camera wasn't all crazy shaky and
insane cuts all the time to make up for
the fact that it's really not to go in
fighting each other yeah
so that's always my concern when I think
of like twin fighting each other
if angley's able to make the cool kind
of artistic action film that he wants to
make this could be something really
special and Will Smith could use a
special film yeah and this could be a
cool opportunity for him to combine his
dramatic chops with his you know more
marketable like action movies got a
little action yeah cuz oh maybe he could
do both like one one of the assassin
dudes that he's playing the older one
could be more serious and the younger
clone who I'm if he doesn't do it will
be played by Jaden Smith yeah whatever
that'll happen that you might have
attracted yes you might attract they're
not going with a really good wolf breath
or come in and say something like that
yeah what about me not playing in your
version but we just get my son to do
beta for McDonald Madonna Madonna biopic
is being made
get it yeah like a virgin walk for the
very first time long time blacklisted
script called Blonde Ambition oh boy I
supposed to take that Jessica Simpson
movie I think so
for her life it's supposed to take place
like during the 80s period when she was
during her first major album on the
process of doing that and loved life and
all that [ __ ]
the strip has apparently been like
blacklisted for a while we don't really
have any information on it no we don't
know who's gonna play or who could
direct it I think Nicholas Winton reppin
should direct this movie it was only
through beacon yeah yeah Dark Soul and
it's about a musician yeah everyone
knows dude love's is a tea style flare
with music you know and Gila and Thomas
yeah I think Nikolas wouldn't reckon
we're the perfect director to do
interesting you'd you just sold me
yeah held me in like half a second I
don't know who could play her though
chloë grace moretz no I don't have to
you're going to have to find somebody
from an already yeah they're going to
think so
I feel like they should it should
audition is I'm one Kevin Feige says
Avengers for title of the spoiler that's
why they haven't revealed it yet I guess
is that the way oh boy speculation here
it comes and no one's ever right now and
again one's ever hit the nail on the
head of any movie when they say here's
what it's going to be called and they
never get it right no one thought
episodes eight would be called the last
Jedi and here we are
whatever Avengers for it like Avengers
for the demands of super yeah treasures
hordes idol is almost a link to whatever
the events are the Infinity war you know
what else Kevin Feige gaze revealed in
talks this week is that Stanley is the
same character oh yeah yeah so every
Stanley is the same him just doing
different [ __ ] I've heard that it's the
same Stanley in even the other Marvel
non MCU movies like Deadpool and x-men
yeah I hear that's all the same
character Stanley brings them all
together
yeah I heard family in real life is that
character Thank You Aaron it's really
his this is the key not even the
original
creator of Marvel he's not even there
was over here of scantling it's just
been a character all this she was been
created by his mom yeah they did happy
John and Reebok they unveiled this is a
new story you mentioned to me three
times this week
they unveiled to Paris collector items I
was expecting an apology there but sure
I guess so thank you having a robot
pre-viability very collector's inside
and inspired by final battle and aliens
the aliens number is featured in a
special two way color pack two color way
back in one yellow and black striped
colorway inspired by Ripley's power
loader robotic cargo suit and the other
in a glossy finish referencing the
xenomorph Queen you can wear a xenomorph
on your foot or out a robo thing that's
where the next alien film should go they
fight all the aliens and instead of
killing them they turn them into some
kind of fur do something Nathan where
they turned them into leather they turn
them into coats dude how sexy would that
be Bonnie by Xena and then it's about
giving the Xenomorphs rights how it's
wrong to kill them and wear it Anna how
they did I be able to live in nature
like how God intended or whoever the
engineers are yeah then maybe our
protagonist is like a young Zita
protester yeah but it all back fires all
back fires and they find out that the
aliens just really wanted
East they don't have a soul they were
specifically designed just to kill
through what is made of absence Jonathan
I never learned to say his last name
Jonathan Demi Danny he passed away at
the age of 73 fantastic director the
films such as Philadelphia and those I
have little lambs and he was smart
enough to not direct Hannibal Red Dragon
and Hannibal Rising he had a really cool
career after that you worked a lot on TV
and documentary saw his IMDB before
filming us he was expendable most of his
last year's TV and a lot of documentary
yeah yeah so we had some things to say
kept working man
and hey like this is kind of inspired me
to go back and take a look at you like
Silence of the Lambs is about time I
watch that movie again yeah you're like
maybe I'll check out some more of his
films too because it's weird they have
nothing to do with lambs no it's just
this one I am so seen where you really
have to pay attention to a Jodie Foster
scene yeah and I guess I'm out easily if
you miss it you might miss the whole
point what call possible and that's on
you movie gotta make there - based on
the movies you got to make a clear only
complaint about one of it's fun thanks
for watching this video the full-length
version is an exclusive segment on
patreon where we actually going to a lot
of commentary this video is actually
like 45 minutes longer than them so if
you want the actual full-length extended
commentary video go join our patreon
jump on and be a member of the new
community my friend a member of the
future of the rigid